spider-man he's a menace ruining my
saturday plans
we got some images that were sent our
way in our facebook requests and they
were blurred and then i saw spiderman no
way home trending on twitter part of the
hashtag so i was like looks like we got
some new images here from empire oh do
you think they would have released that
yesterday no they're doing the dc fandom
thing let's just put the flash trailer
out once it's all done yeah that makes
sense yeah totally it's quite the
controversy you were following there
right the topical reference right now
yeah dude all right i don't know i guess
we'll just go random here there's only
two images no and then let's unblur one
of them
let's just see what the first one is
drum roll
okay i feel like that image is supposed
to be awesome
and i don't know it looks like a meme i
find it just kind of goofy
because
because spider-man is gonna have the
word me plastered all over it and then
ock is gonna have like a phrase of like
my responsibility yeah or like whatever
the thing you wanna plug into when i
fight with my girlfriend on the freeway
spider-man know what home spoilers mean
yeah exactly i don't know i mean the doc
image looks like just so super cgi as
expected it would be i like the context
around it this is just an image i'm not
gonna judge this scene based off this
one still alone
but i will talk about what this one
still alone is ultimately making me feel
and uh i think it's kind of goofy it
looks like a mcu
silly scene of spider-man
running away in this iron spider suit it
looks like they screen capped it and
they didn't bother to find a clear frame
they kind of took the first frame when
they hit pause they just took a
screenshot of it i love the idea of him
using vehicles to be tossing at
spider-man as part of an action sequence
yes absolutely that sounds back to the
second movie spider-man 2. definitely
and uh we could probably guarantee that
this scene is definitely not toby
mcguire unless empire's really in on it
too
the scene is not toby mcguire it is
indeed tom holland that we could chalk
that whole thing up to totem guard just
being a theory but i don't know i just
like you think about like toby mcguire
versus doc and you think he'd stand his
crowd he was blue
that's what this image looks like just
like
way more just it doesn't even look like
an intense like fearful runner like
looking over his shoulder to try to
dodge
it literally because reed's funny
everybody's funny okay i'm not saying
the scene will be funny maybe maybe
there's a joke moment here i'm just but
i'm thinking that it looks a little
goofy here it's the build-up
the music rises he says hello peter
there's a beat
and then peter turns around
that way
okay that's cool
oh
is this the statue of liberty fight it's
gotta be
spoilers confirmed because his mask is
off and usually in spider-man movies
that's a finale move yeah that's a
finale thing is when mask off all
dirty messed up they've teased quite a
bit that the fight would be on the
statue of liberty i just don't know what
the top of the statue of liberty looks
like
let's see if we can match any
images
to the ground here let's look at this
image again really quick okay there's a
bit of that orange glow thing at the
bottom here
which could indicate
um that it's magic hour
no
the doc
what is that yeah yeah that like source
of power that he's building and creating
what is that thing called i type for the
life of me definitely not an art reactor
i forget what that thing is called or it
could just be from the actual maybe the
statue of liberty the torch or the torch
the torch or maybe it's like you know
the the the inner workings of her crown
i'm just looking for some floor panels
that might slightly resemble her head so
yeah maybe i'm saying it might have been
taken off she's like someone sliced off
the top or no it could be on the torch
right here yeah it could be it could be
on the outside that's a good a good
ceramization uh actually no but if you
look inside there's this of this
thumbnail well to make sure this is in
the video this thumbnail that orange
glow is similar to what was on the
reflective floor panel there maybe doc
ock is trying to reignite his work in
the top of the statue literally that's
what i'm thinking yeah kind of like how
they did that in x-men with magneto yeah
yeah we won and then maybe he
decapitates
he not decapitates he scalps the statue
delivered his head that is the least
exposure we want in the spiderman i mean
come on look at that this is a similar
orange glow if people are going to be
like that saying in the corner sandman
i'm going to say this is 100 evidence
confirmation yeah that this is indeed
statue of liberty confirmed liberty yeah
could be i mean they're good images one
image is significantly more badass than
the other
but it's kind of like a character art
for spider-man it is he starts out as a
wimp and then learns now i can't run
away from my problems man i gotta be
crisp and clear
he grows a level of confidence over time
which is you know that's what you want
for peter parker and this is classic
traditional spider-man pose and if this
is from the finale fight it looks like
after all those suits he goes back a
little bit more to his uh
to his root suit is this yeah i mean
it's still different yeah but it's not
exactly the same but you know it's not
an iron spider or an integrated thing or
a dr strange suit or nothing it's just
petey parker a lot of times the little
details
fly over my head on suits oh it's like
oh they changed this like one little
patch that's a little stripper yeah
definitely never noticed something like
that yeah
this is cool man this is cool this could
mean that a tree the fact that they're
putting these images out could mean that
there is a trailer definitely right
around the corner here i mean it's going
to be november so yeah imagine that
there's going to be a trailer pretty
soon you know
i'd be i'd be very surprised if we don't
get it in the next week or two
actually i wouldn't be at this point
with spider-man they can do whatever
they could put it out a week before it
would be like tickets now on sale flight
to the death worth december 10th trailer
number two
all right guys what do you think about
these images did you find that image of
doc badass or goofy sorry if i offended
you send us your best meme of it
hey subscribe click that notification
bell john you got one hour to get this
video up
i'm gonna do it it's gonna be good but
there we should do a pic
niraj krishnan naraj i'm going to shout
you out like john
niraj
you are such a good dude man
like you with the music that you keep
recommending us and the raj you know
obviously i can totally see they if
there was anyone who was going to fight
doc ock it would be
you
look to look to john if i doing okay
you're doing something okay yeah narage
like i'm staring into a mirror i could
see you going up there using some of
that indian background to outsmart doc
ock
into a fight you would not just use the
physicality yes you would cower away and
run away at first but then you would
fight him on top of the statue of
liberty because you represent liberty
man um i love you dude you are uh you've
been a great pal of us for so long i
miss you man i haven't talked to you in
uh quite a long time uh this is the
greatest hits this is awesome
you got a garage
[Music]
you